intruder at the home of the U.S national
security advisor has renewed scrutiny of
the U.S Secret Service at a time of
increased threats against public figures
before that intrusion Adriana Diaz sat
down with secret service director Kim
Cheadle this is her first Network TV
interview since taking over eight months
ago and they met at a secret service
facility outside Washington
at the secret service training center
drivers show us how they work so this
would be if you're
running away from something
did you get out of the area
protect the president the get out of
here in a hurry
okay
with Maneuvers like j-turns about face
and keep it moving
nearby officers trained to take down a
would-be White House fence jumper
but in this empty field there's no real
fence so this bike rack is how you do
your White House fence training yeah
this bike rack is a representation of
what we have is the north fence line
downtown and the White House the White
House is the the trees you see back
there Sergeant Daria Nall says his
officers have to use their imagination
running through trees as if there were
rooms in the White House how much of a
disadvantage is that from a training
perspective it could be a huge
disadvantage secret service director Kim
Cheadle agrees one of your predecessors
said training without a White House
replica is like training for a
basketball game without Hoops absolutely
I think you wouldn't ask your Super Bowl
champs to go out and train in a parking
lot that's why she wants Congress to
fund a replica White House for training
your team has gone to an unusual place
as part of the research on how to build
a mock White House I'm thinking about a
Hollywood related place they visited
Tyler Perry's Production Studio in
Atlanta which has a replica White House
he was gracious enough to allow us to
take a tour of it did it feel like the
white house uh it did she would know the
28-year veteran was on the team that
evacuated Vice President Dick Cheney on
9 11. and she served on then Vice
President Biden's protective detail he
named her director in mid-2022
amid a swirl of controversy over the
agency deleting nearly all of its text
messages from January 6. the agency says
that was due to a data migration system
migrations happen but I think for a lot
of Americans it just doesn't pass the
smell test given the timing and the
volume of messages deleted well it's
unfortunate that that would be the
assumption that people would make our
integrity is everything and there was
nothing nefarious attached to that their
integrity has been put to the test not
only by the mishap at the National
Security advisor's home but by
misconduct over the years including
off-duty agents hiring sex workers in
Colombia before an Obama trip and a
drunken altercation in South Korea last
year we've implemented a number of
things previous to to me becoming the
director and then continuing as I've
been the director I've made sure that
the workforce knows that misconduct
won't be tolerated we ensure that
there's a full investigation that's
taken place whenever there is an
allegation if we need to put a person on
admin leave or revoke their security
clearance we'll do that another
challenge recruitment and retention
something all law enforcement is
struggling with but the secret Services
departure rate was 48 last year due in
part to the high demands of the job
to expand hiring they're aiming to have
30 percent women recruits by 2030 and
even allowed YouTube influencer Michelle
Kari to train with agents but I'm very
conscious uh as uh as I sit in this
chair now of making sure that we need to
attract diverse candidates and ensure
that we are developing and giving
opportunities to everybody in our
Workforce and particularly women that
Workforce will be pivotal for the 2024
campaign season which for the first time
includes a former president who already
has lifetime protection
agents were there when Donald Trump was
arraigned in New York we were able to
work out the details ahead of time of
how that particular day was going to go
but we will always ensure the safety of
all of our protectees that we have the
service has a zero fail Mission emission
officers are training to uphold
pretending this field is the most famous
address in America
for CBS mornings I'm Adriana Diaz in
Laurel Maryland
I mean well the secret service has had
some missteps recently yeah but what we
know about them is they are really
dedicated women to doing that job I
think it's a hard job to do and they
work very very well zero fail is a hard
standard as well I think they have a
point about training with no white house
to train in no replica of course to
model their actions on I love that they
reach out to Tyler Perry I've been to
that replica and I'm telling you it's a
spot yeah I have it's spot on we should
tell the viewers that while the while
the piece was falling you're here off
camera being like they should talk
that's exactly what happened and then
the next line was Tyler
48 departure rate that number is
shocking but then when you think about
the demands on this job I mean you're
literally putting your life on the line
every time you step out your front is
that zero fail Tony they got me you'd
want to trade I would love to yeah let's
set that up I would love to feel that
intensity I've always that thought that
that's one of the most dangerous jobs in
America at any moment